welcome everyone to today's webinar I
hope to talk a little bit about how
computational notebooks can be a useful
tool for teaching and research and so
from the previous polls I saw that there
were a good number of educators in
higher education secondary education and
also some enthusiasts who were just
interested in working with notebooks
more than 50% of you have been creating
your notebooks already and a quarter of
you are new to notebooks so I'll try to
strike the balance there I'll talk about
a few basics and so the pros please be
patient but then I will also not linger
too much and move on to the more
interesting aspect of what we hope to
present today the computational essays
idea so let's get started I was hoping
to talk briefly about what the Wolfram
notebook is for the newcomers and also
point to a few different venues where
you can access and open and work with a
Wolfram notebook then I would like to
move on to some of the features of the
Wolfram notebook that make it useful in
teaching and research I want to
highlight some of the features that help
in these two venues and then finally I
want to end with one specific use of the
notebook that is to write the
computational essay which Stephen
Wolfram talked about in his blog post
and which we hope you will find as a
very useful mechanism in both presenting
your content in while teaching or even
to ask your students to submit their
work in the form of computation assist
you assess their understanding down the
line also maybe you might find it useful
to have conversation analysis of certain
kinds in recording your research or just
to talk about any topic that you find
interesting
so the Wolfram notebook is the original
notebook that was pioneered by Wolfram
almost 30 years back so we had the
notebook right from the beginning
although most of our original users used
it as a programming interface it has so
many more features that can be explored
as you have probably the one those of
you who have been using notebooks are
used to the fact that you know you it's
not just code you can include text
graphics so much more and what it also
provides access to is being the
programming interface for the Wolfram
language it provides access to this huge
collection of algorithms through the
built-in functions we have 500 plus
built-in functions in the world from
language and also a great collection of
high-quality curated data through the
built-in knowledge base that comes along
with the Wolfram language and then
finally notebooks are highly integrated
and cross-platform so you know you can
create a notebook in on your device and
then go ahead and share it without
worrying with other people who are able
to open it in a different world from
products so for example we have the
well-known Mathematica that's the
desktop product that you can install on
your system and then you can open
wolfram notebooks from within
Mathematica or you can also have Wolfram
notebooks in the cloud so we have the
Wolfram cloud so you are able to look at
notebooks in the browser across systems
and then of course we also have the
Wolfram player for it's currently only
for iOS devices but you know if you're
looking at it from the students
perspective who like to look at things
on their mobile devices and if you are
trying to distribute content your
lecture content one from player is an
option for looking at notebooks that you
create so as I just said you can look at
Wolfram notebooks across different
products so let's take a look at the
Wolfram open cloud here so this is free
access and I will be sharing these links
that I am clicking and opening
from so bare with me you will have
access to all this information so we had
these things to try notebook on the free
cloud the open T of the Wolfram open
cloud and I believe that it's a very
interesting point for newcomers to get
started you can just you know try out
different things here and these things
to try not bug and get the flavor of
working with Wolfram notebooks other
than that if you are unsure what what
sort of a product is useful for you I
mean if you are an educator you might be
at one of our Wolfram sites which has
the Mathematica site license and so you
might have quick and easy access to
Mathematica if you're unsure about that
we have this page here where you can
fill in your information and it will
tell you whether or not you have access
to the Wolfram site license and our
customer service people would be more
than happy to help you out with that if
you're looking for personal use we
suggest the Wolfram one subscription
which is a hybrid between desktop and
cloud technology where you can work with
notebooks online in the cloud but then
also work on work on them offline using
the Wolfram desktop and then of course I
showed the Wolfram player for more
information about what which will from
license etc you would like to use for
your education related work please feel
free to visit our website here so if you
were going to introduce the Wolfram
notebook to your students
I wanted to list out some quick a quick
list of features that might be useful in
pointing out to your students that this
is the way you know this is the stuff
that is available to you and you would
be able to use if you were going to work
with a word for notebook if you if they
have access to the desktop product great
otherwise again you can open up the a
notebook in the cloud so I was showing
you the things to try notebook let me
bring that up back here you can work
with that or you can you know just open
up and you
not book from file new notebook here in
the open cloud and be able to work with
that so you know you have the standard
stuff you can have text here and then
you can of course have code here and you
can evaluate code you can do other
things like use the suggestion bar here
you know which for a newcomer it gently
introduces new things and says oh okay
by the way we have some suggestions do
you want to do this or that say you want
to do you want to look at the number of
primes less than 8 give little hints to
ease people into using the Wolfram
language in the notebook so text code
images things like that you can point
out to your students that you have this
hierarchical structure in the notebooks
with the help of cells and cell brackets
so for example if I were to make this of
the style see a section I make this I go
in here and I go to the formatting menu
here and I changes to this to a section
so I have a section here which is
actually collapsible and this keeps my
document a much more organized so I can
also have another section here and again
I can change this to section and so your
student can now write new stuff in this
and organize their work nicely formatted
nicely for presentation in class or just
to submit their work so this
hierarchical structure of the document
makes it very valuable for presentation
and it is also easily processed in a
program itself because you know the the
notebook and the notebook itself is made
the Wolfram language it's a Wolfram
language expression and is amenable to
programming so this hierarchical
structure helps with that so yes there
is this intuitive programming interface
this code assist code completion when
you start typing in notebooks on the
desktop product little hints appear
suggesting that is this the function you
were trying to write and it helps you
along when you are not sure there is
also extensive documentation available
and let me pull up our the in product
documentation Center so here you you can
access information about all the
different world from language functions
and it is interactive itself so you can
go in here and play around with the code
to better understand what it's doing so
you know for example I can go and edit
and then run it and see okay this is
what this particular function does okay
it creates a list of squares of numbers
from 1 to 20 and so you know of course
if I make it hundred it will create the
squares for one two hundred so an
interactive documentation and the
function names are expressive themselves
so you have somewhat of an idea of what
the function name might be you go and
search for it in the documentation
Center and then our search will bring up
that particular function that you need
to use the notebook can also hand
natural language queries where you know
you just type in an equal sign and then
type in in natural language some
particular query and then the notebook
is able to interpret it and we'll look
at an example of that when we look at
the computational essays so these are
the various features I hope that you are
able to introduce to your students and
get them excited and work on using word
from notebooks so moving from students
to the educators themselves the teachers
I know as teachers you are always
looking out for technology that will
help you in your classrooms to teach
your students I mean from personal
experience have worked with some amazing
professors as TA
I've always appreciated how they bring
in technology to aid their students
understand things better so the wolf of
notebooks we feel would help in in
teaching in many different ways so
starting out with the rich authoring
environment that the wolfram notebook
offers so if you are looking to create
computable documents lesson plans
lectures and handouts quizzes slides and
so on you can use the word from notebook
for that in fact this presentation that
I'm giving this this is us this slide
deck was created in the Wolfram language
using a special version of the word from
notebooks as the presenter tools so it
just you know converts the notebook into
a slideshow and you know it gives
associated features to for a
presentation so I have my notebook but
then I have also the useful things that
I need to make it into a slideshow
presentation but let me show you a few
examples of things that were created in
wolfram notebooks so this is a lesson on
solids of revolution the the simplest
possible notebook so you can see how the
styling options were applied to you know
nicely format the document with you know
titles sections text images which was
created in the Wolfram language itself
equipped mathematical equations and so
on so an example of a handout that you
might use in class an example of quiz
here's an example of a calculus quiz
that was created with a Wolfram notebook
where this the student can provide the
answers in the notebook itself
let me see another example of lab
exercise so this is in lab exercise
where we have this interactive document
where the student can play around with
this information here so the I think the
question is to examine this model and
then answer some questions here so there
is this interactive piece here that the
student can play around with
and then you have to provide the answers
in here so the sample of a lab exercise
let me just quickly point out to the
newcomers how easy to it is to access
these style definitions so of course you
have the format menu and I'm doing all
this in the desktop product of
Mathematica a lot of these options are
also available in Word from desktop are
not the entire suite but enough to help
you work with notebooks in in the
Wolfram cloud it's pretty user friendly
so you have the formatting the regular
formatting menu to do format your stuff
but you also have the very advanced
style sheet so for example I can go to
the format menu and I can edit the style
sheet for this notebook as you can see I
have a very customized style sheet here
but I can make changes here and you know
for example I can say I want all my text
to have a background color of gray which
probably will make my slideshow hideous
but you know that is that is one option
so you see how like CSS for HTML we have
our style sheets and you are able to use
it like a pro to style your documents
then we have different palettes here
under palettes we have the classroom
assistant which I hope you will find
useful let me bring it to the center
where we have put together useful
writing formatting templating tools so
you know you can just pick the template
from here and then fill it out to create
like a professionally typeset document
so that's all about writing and styling
then including text and graphics so we
have the graphics menu where you can use
the drawing tools palette to actually
create some graphics in your document
itself you know some basic shapes and
styling of those shapes etc or you can
just use the Wolfram language itself to
create graphics and then work with it
you can the
interactive you can resize it restyle it
you know we can have 3d plots and you
can interact with it you know make it
look just right for your document for
images we have the image editing
interface so for example I can actually
select this image here let's try to make
it a little smaller
my little image editing toolbar is
hiding underneath here so I'm trying to
bring it up so I can show it to you
okay let's actually let's let's do this
let's bring this up to the top of the
notebook so we can work with it better
okay
here is the image editing toolbar that I
was talking about if I click on more it
opens up here and so an interactive way
to work with images so here for example
we have the interface to actually work
with a number of our very advanced image
processing functions that you can access
from this menu itself and work with your
images so just another quick example of
the ease of access to a lot of
complicated stuff from within the
wolfram notebook itself another element
that we can bring in is the element of
interactivity so all explanations come
to life if you can add some elements of
interactivity to it so for example if we
were going to look at the effect of
amplitude and frequency on a sine wave
yes we can create a static plot and then
we can recreate that plot by changing
the amplitude and frequency so for
example here I have two variables and I
keep changing them and I would have to
evaluate it over and over and again if I
wanted to show my students hey look if I
change the amplitude you will see a
different sine wave
the different amplitude here but it
becomes so much easier if I create this
as a manipulate so now I can
interactively show the effect of the
amplitude I can show the you know this
is some people jokingly refer to this as
proof by slider where you just you know
you can move around the slider and now
you can show your students how how
things actually work when you change the
parameters but the point I hope I'm
trying to make here is that the ease
with which this interactivity shows your
students the effect of certain
parameters on certain phenomenon very
easily the the manipulate here is like
the simplest of examples of
interactivity that the notebooks can
bring to you I have included with the
material in this presentation a more
complicated example this was created by
one of our developers so this is an
interactive presentation on earthquakes
and this was created with the same idea
of like you know interactivity
interactivity bringing more information
and helping someone understand a
particular phenomenon or providing them
the information of in a more interesting
way so hopefully this provides some
inspiration for using notebooks for your
lessons I'm going to go ahead and set my
styling back so that I do not so that my
prison
doesn't look all weird so yes so we
talked about interactivity the other
point and I wanted to make is the quick
access to these complex algorithms so
you know now it is we have access to a
lot of data and then I'm pretty sure in
a lot of your classes you are trying to
work with data and there are certain
things that you would like to try out
the in the Wolfram language we have
built-in functions to do a lot of
complex things so that you can focus on
your lesson and you don't have to write
code from scratch so for example just
looking at data or exploring data I have
some example data here and say I want to
just look at a scatter plot of the data
points in two dimensions so one option
would be to look at the feature space
plot which you know plots out these data
points in a two dimensional space and we
can see very easily that how the colors
cluster together the greens on one end
the blues the yellows and the Reds or if
I actually want to use a well
established clustering algorithm to look
at the data I can do that with the help
of one of the other built-in functions
find cluster and I can even mention
which particular algorithm to use or if
I even want to quickly visualize the
clusters I can use yet another built-in
function for that purpose so I do not
want to like overwhelm you showing oh oh
here all the different things to you can
do I want to point you to the resources
that are available from within the
Wolfram notebook itself to try out new
things which I hope will aid in in your
lesson so access to algorithms access to
interactivity let's move on to access to
data so I mentioned that we have the
built-in knowledge base so for example
if you are you know for you in your
class you're talking about the economics
of South America and you want to look at
the GDP for Brazil's GDP we have the
built in country data available that you
can invoke to get this particular
information and so of course it's not
just for Brazil but you can get it for
all the different kinds
of South America and why limit yourself
to South America you can make this
interactive and get the information for
all the different continents so now you
can explore together with your students
a particular information to compare and
visualize different kinds of data yet
another example I have here is for a
chemical data that is again another a
built-in data set there are a huge
number of examples here if you look at
the Wolfram documentation you will see
here we have this section here on
different kinds of data that geographic
data engineering data financial data
social cultural linguistic data and I
will leave it to you to explore these
different things and see if there is
something that you might find
particularly useful for your class and
not just the built-in data you have
access to your own data there are a
whole number of different types of file
formats that is supported in the Wolfram
language so we can just see how many
really right now we support over 200
different file formats that can be
imported so if you want to import a CSV
data file here is an example of how you
could do it or as we find sometimes
useful nowadays scraping data of the web
so here is an example of saying
importing images from websites if you
only want to look at the images from
that website so the import function can
deal with it easily you know all you
have to do is give it the URL so here's
another example of just yet if you are
trying to do some data analysis on the
data script of those websites so for
example I want to see what this
particular page is really talking about
and I create a word cloud of all the
text that I scrape off this website so
this is the world what a wildlife page
about red pandas it's nice to see they
are talking about red pandas things that
immediately come to view is okay they
are
endangered species it talks about their
habitats and so on to other useful
resources I would like you to like to
point out to you is the Wolfram data
repository where we have actually
curated data from different resources
the difference being that here anyone
can submit the data if you have a nice
data set you can submit it to the
Wolfram data repository and once it is
approved it is up there available for
anyone to use and what's great about it
is that it is ready in a computable
format so you can just get the data from
the Wolfram data repository it has been
cleaned up formatted things that take
forever when you're actually working
with raw data but when you download it
from the data repository it's good to go
you have it and you can just work with
it so here I have an example of
downloading the global mean temperature
from 1880 onwards I downloaded from the
Wolfram data repository and then there
is a quick example of actually working
with that data so I'll skip it in the
interest of time right now but you will
have access to this notebook and you
should be able to try out so the the
notebook is the perfect tool for writing
a computational essay and here we have
provided an example of computation assay
so for example say you have a lesson you
are preparing on the Ring of Fire the
idea of the computational essay is that
you will include text and you would also
include code that provides some useful
information that augments the text and
so now what you have here is not just
things that a student can read but they
have this protis code here which they
can interact where they can play around
with and hopefully the result of running
that code will enhance their
understanding so for example in this
little piece about the Ring of Fire I'm
getting the earthquake recorded between
2010 and now now if your student is
interested in getting earthquakes for a
different different period of time
becomes so much easier for them to play
around with the code and get this new
data and look at it
so here I've tried to show how to
include a combined both code and the
built-in functions from the Wolfram
language and the graphics resulting from
running those functions to create this
little bit about the Ring of Fire now
the same computational essay can also be
a student report for example if your
student was asked to write a report on
the recent earthquakes in Hawaii this
would be a computational I say that they
could come up with so for example here
this dude this is a hypothetical student
coming up looking at the information of
the Hawaii earthquakes and then coming
up with the observation that a whole
bunch of smaller magnitude earthquakes
seemed to precede the large an
earthquake of a high magnitude so an
example of a computational essay as
student work then if a student was
investigating a particular topic for
doing some research on it the
computational essay could also be just
his lab journal where he gets
information from the Wolfram language
and here are all examples of how you
could use the word from language in the
notebook itself the built-in database
the the built in entity informations
from the Wolfram language to create a
lab journal on the earthquake the
different volcanoes in Hawaii so I
wanted to point out some examples of
computational assays from the Wolfram
summer school so I a few from them and
all these students come from very
diverse backgrounds not all of them had
programming background so they just came
in they picked a topic of their choice
that they wanted to write about so here
is an example this is a computational
essay on money and the idea of money a
very short discussion on the circulation
of money in the network
someone from economics back
and they put together this computation
essay with the idea that you know
without much background on the topic
itself someone should be able to read
this computational essay and have an
understanding of what it is talking
about here's another one about the
purpose graph I believe this is by a
sophomore or freshman actually in
college who discusses this particular
kind of a graph and its properties and
then a bunch of other graph theory
related topics about this particular
purpose graph here is someone who comes
from astrophysics background they did a
competition let's say on exoplanets and
they make use of the built in entities
and they analyzed the different kinds of
information that is available again in
the Wolfram language itself about
exoplanets through the exoplanet data
function and they show how you know
things like Doppler spectroscopy or
radial velocity method can be used to
actually determine certain
characteristics of these exoplanets
another person he is again also from a
physics background he explored
earthquakes and gutenberg-richter law so
the idea behind sharing these
computational essays and you will notice
that I am opening them up in the browser
these so these essays these notebooks
competitions notebooks containing the
essays have been deployed to the cloud
and so it is out there accessible to
anyone and it is still providing that
interactivity and the rich data the
images to talk about this particular
topic
the idea behind sharing these essays
with you is the hope that you will be
able to use this form of narrative in
your class too and
find it useful so I would like to end
with few tips it's as Stephen Wolfram
suggested for writing these computation
and essays thinks that you might want to
keep in mind if you were going to use
these for your students things like you
know keep the ratio between text and
code keep the code simple while it is
easy to get carried away and write
really cool complex code the idea in the
computation I say is that the code
itself should add to the explanation so
someone reading this they should be able
to read the code and see okay I see what
this is doing even if they have no
knowledge of the programming language
itself try to explain what the code is
doing provide some annotations of the
code and then we have some technical
suggestions that will help keep the code
simple so they you know people don't get
lost in details of the code that they
don't really want to know they just want
to look at the code and understand oh I
see this this creates you know a
timeline a plot of some sort of
financial data for some time period and
things like that so I have included this
in the notebook should you choose to use
competition that says I hope you will
find these tips interesting we will I
will leave you with a list of few
references that I hope you will find
useful I'll go ahead and turn over the
microphone to dr. Kyle Kim here we do
want to actually hear about the
interesting work he has been doing the
real life scenario where he has been
using wolfram notebooks in his class
okay yes I am a lecturer inside of the
Department of material science and
engineering at MIT one of my main
charges is to bring computation into
each aspect of the curriculum we believe
that coding and computation needs to be
folded into the modern scientist
training as much as mathematics
and science communication so we believe
coding is a fundamental skill that each
scientist needs to have to accomplish
that goal at MIT and the physics cross
of the freshman year we're bringing
coding into the basic mechanics and the
electricity and magnetism classes so
physics kind of 101 and 102 we call them
801 and 802 and then inside of my
department we are dealing with the fret
the sophomores who are coming in to our
department now they're specialized in
material science but they have have very
little coding experience and so we have
a class to get them jump-started called
computational methods for material
science and engineering so those are the
two classes that I currently teach that
bring a lot of coding into them thank
you guys so what are the different ways
in which you're using wolfram notebooks
in these classes I do everything inside
of well for notebooks which is probably
why I'm on the webinar is what for
notebooks are my tool for preparing
lectures they're my tool for giving out
readings before class I run a flipped
classroom so there are the tools that I
use to give interactive readings before
class and then when students show up in
class I use them to sometimes lecture
with pre-built materials as well as do
live coding in front of the students I
believe that students need to see
failure and struggle model modeled
inside of the classroom so I just open
up a blank notebook and I would and then
I will give them exams that include
parts where they have to code and
complete exercises that I've begun and
students work in small groups to create
what you're calling computational essays
they create these computational
narratives where they explain a topic
and their job is to weave mathematical
logic
reasoning and including all simultaneous
imal taneous lis into an argument that
convinces me that they understand a
physical phenomenon yeah can you show us
some examples of the notebooks I'm
pretty sure our attendees would love to
look at these examples absolutely I
would start with so I prepared the story
of how I started to use notebooks in the
classroom so the first thing that I did
is I opened up a notebook and I solved a
problem that I found interesting and so
I wanted to teach students how to
visualize a three-dimensional field so
in electric electricity and magnetism
students are often shown that these type
of two-dimensional diagrams and so I
show them how to code those diagrams so
they can see this is connected to what
they're learning in their textbook and
then I go on and it's just a small bit
more code and you can get to a
three-dimensional visualization and then
you realize that an electric field is
not just a two-dimensional thing it is
in fact a three-dimensional thing and
you can look at it from different angles
and get very different symmetries so now
I have a very interactive
three-dimensional visualization where
students can explore electric field and
a much more tangible and meaningful
three-dimensional way so here I look at
the different planes and if you cut
along one of these planes you see the
standard visualization but they can
understand them that adds they rotate
that they'll see different symmetries
and you know hopefully start to think of
electric fields as three-dimensional
things so now I have students not
writing new code inside of this this is
for the freshman physics courses so
they're very doing very minor edits on
the code this is much more using the
three-dimensional visualization and
showing them how to represent electric
fields in a computer algebra system
inside of code they're coding language
so I can jump to the next one unless you
have any questions on that
you know why not show us some of the
examples of the computational narratives
you refer to or one before that okay
yeah so so after you create these
notebooks where it's you as a teacher
are learning how to code for yourself
inside of a notebook and you share that
with your students sometimes you get
really excited and you create really
interactive things so these become a bit
more code than you would want your
students to start to interact with and
if I come along here and I'm creating
what's known as a binary phase diagram
by doing a convex whole along the free
energy curves so this is kind of
advanced material science but this
computational method is a fundamental
thing that you need your students to
understand in material science and so I
got a bit too excited and they spent
many hours building out a tool that
would help students understand this so
this is something that I wouldn't give
the code when I say I use notebooks to
deliver this to my students so that they
can understand what is normally shown as
a sequence of images in their textbook
this lets me take that visualization a
lot further and allows them to edit the
underlying physics and see how it
effects this binary yeah I think one
great example of what we were referring
to earlier in the presentation is
incorporating interactivity for better
student understanding and here you see a
great example and here Kyle is giving
you live demo of how exactly so it is so
easy to create a slider with just that
little function there slider right at
the bottom of a screen you can see that
he's just creating this as we are
talking he's creating a simple slider in
the notebook itself right so this is me
programming inside of a notebook and
I'll create a slider that lets me
dynamically change the value inside of
my notebook so this is not just a place
to put static code this is very living
breathing
you know computation so the next stage
after I get overly excited and build out
things that are more advanced then I
want my students to build is I step over
into a full what's kind of called a
scaffold it fade it example so inside of
my notebook I start to remove some
content and then I make that a space
where students need to step in and fill
in the missing parts so I want them to
learn how to code full narratives so in
order to do that I write a full
narrative and then I remove some content
and then I ask them to finish it so yeah
and I was just commenting I would love
to be in yes it's so interesting but
it's amazing then like you are it's not
just subject specific you are also
tricking them into learning coding while
they are learning the content the the
content from your specific for this
specific topic so that's that's a great
idea as well so Kyle go ahead I was
going to say it's not even just tricking
them to learn coding we're actually
doing a research right now collecting
data our hypothesis is that you you
actually have increased learning
outcomes for the context for the physics
if you teach them physics through coding
so we're running some educational
research studies right now on EDX in
order to determine whether or not adding
this type of computational narrative
actually increases learning outcomes
within the subject that they're doing it
in right thanks guys in the interest of
time we'll move on to a little bit about
the another way you have used notebooks
is that in the cloud-based course could
you quickly show us a little bit how
you've used it in a way from notebooks
in the MIT X online learning course
right so there's two two ways that I
currently use that inside of MITx
which is a variant of EDX and similar to
Moodle or Coursera you can embed a
simple iframe so if I want to let my
students code without having to worry
about grading then I can give them the
cloud notebook directly inside of an
iframe so this is not just a widget that
they're playing with they can actually
come in to this notebook and write code
for themselves and run that code so I
can give them examples of things such as
creating and manipulate to study the
different frequencies and what it means
to increase or decrease the frequency of
a periodic function then they can come
and get that same interactivity inside
of the class so in our physics 101 and
102 courses we have them create these
interactive so that they can start to
study the relationship between something
as simple as sine of a frequency x and
looking at what changing that frequency
does the second way that we use
notebooks inside of these online courses
is using an LTI framework which mean
yeah it's unfortunate I think we are
losing Kyle a little bit all the way
from India here maybe the connection is
not that great but I think what he was
highlighting that these online learning
platforms they have their framework and
you're able to use the Wolfram notebooks
within that framework so he was giving
an example of that of how he has used
these notebooks in the MIT X for the MIT
X EDX platform will very quickly discuss
a few questions if you have something
specific you would like to ask Kyle or
if there are any other questions Jaime
we should be looking at is there
something that you would like us to talk
about